for reaction I talked to Republican
senator bob Corker of tennessee just a
short time ago senator corker good to
see you thanks for first time on the
Ingraham angle so late I know well we
kept you up but let's talk about today
big news day did this really surprise
you Rex Tillerson out today by the
president did you ever think he was a
great fit I thought he was a really good
at giving sound advice I've known for
some time I talked to both of them often
and I've known it hasn't been a perfect
fit so was I surprised not really but I
will say since December 1st right around
that time you felt a reprieve you felt
like that they were working better
together so the the story today was this
is chaos people are freaking out in the
meadow there's just more chaos and it
turns out that the president is
apparently considering also firing the
VA secretary after the story broke that
he was on some sightseeing trip I guess
in Europe on an official business
Shulkin might be out replaced by Rick
Perry thoughts on that I think Rick will
be good at anything does he's been a
good governor obviously but look this is
as I was telling you earlier the
reporters in the hallway have almost
become - you know this is just sort of
normal and changes are occurring and you
know the president needs someone a
secretary of state that he has a lot of
faith in and again I thought Rex did a
very good job he has a great
relationship with mattis which is very
unusual and the two of them always go in
on the same page and I don't know Pompeo
very well but I do hear very good things
about him when we look forward he's
gonna be in the office later this week I
look forward to a good compromise well
that the thought is the
internationalists the interventionists
in the Republican Party are kind of on
the downslide and the more nationalist
populist wing is on the ascendancy
because of course Pompeo is more in line
with Trump Tillerson is more I think
more in line with you know your thinking
and what are your thoughts on that is it
better to have that tension where the
internationalists are are kind of vying
for the president's ear now I would use
the word realist okay fine I say
you you use your terminology and I think
the you know the President's speech
which we lauded I was the first person I
think the log one was foreign policy
speech speeches had the the makings of a
Jim Baker kind of realist world so I
don't I don't necessarily look at him as
a nationalist I mean he is you know in
Afghanistan doing what he's doing and
committed to not something that's
divined by time and and so much so he's
a mix he's a he's more of a realist I do
think it's good to have countering
voices and the president does as well
and he actually likes hearing the debate
I mean he talked about that a great deal
in the Gary cone when he left so look I
think that as long as as long as whoever
is working with him regardless of what
their point of view is is giving him the
full collage of opportunities to think
about things then I think that's funny
but Tillerson couldn't answer the
question did you call him a [ __ ] I mean
that's just that's just not gonna work
well and remember Barack Obama fired
only a few people I mean McChrystal he
fired mattis remember when he fired
mattis he didn't even tell him Matt has
learned about it I guess secondhand
third-hand so people people switch up
positions when the chemistry isn't right
I think the president said chemistry
just wasn't there well as the president
called this morning on his way out west
about 10 o'clock from Air Force One and
as I mentioned him look every one of
these people serve at his pleasure so
it's his decision and and the new CIA
chief would be Gina Hass ball who's been
with the CIA for 30 years she'd be the
first woman to ever had that agency she
is not going without criticism today
this is a former FBI Special Agent Ally
Stefan who was on MSNBC earlier today
let's watch there's a show of torture
but also there's issue of the
destruction of videotapes evidence on
torture right and that happened in
violation to a federal judge's order so
now this is another thing that need to
come out during the confirmation hearing
we need to know what she thinks about
these issues the left is gearing up to
go after Gina Haspel who is an
undercover for most of her career is
being lauded even by some former Obama
administration officials like I think
clap
today what of that I think we're going
to see with these changes maybe three of
them you mentioned one that I was
unaware of earlier probably likely to
see a pretty partisan environment over
the next couple of months we have a
article today out about how the new
omnibus spending bill might not defund
sanctuary cities and I saw that today
and I thought wait a second now we got
the House and the Senate in Republican
hands I got a Republican president
Republicans in election time are really
big on defunding things we're gonna do
this we're gonna take the money from
Planned Parenthood we're gonna defund
sanctuary cities and now it looks like
they might not do that meaning you guys
might not do that and I'm thinking what
planet am i living on what is your view
on the sanctuary city issue president's
out in California today I think we
should follow through on defunding them
now this is a decision made by McConnell
Ryan Schumer and Pelosi okay they're the
ones that are the final deciders I have
no idea what's in the Omni what I do
know that's a problem
I mean I think the house may vote under
this Friday we're supposed to take it up
next week but regardless of the
defunding which I hope occurs it's a
god-awful amount of money we're spending
two trillion dollars more over the next
decade if we go through with this
process which we are so I think the
American people ought to be alarmed by
the massive amount of spending this in
this bill and we ought to defund
sanctuary cities you were close to not
voting for that tax bill because it
really wasn't why a lot of us wanted in
a tax bill but nevertheless it does feel
like it's juice the economy and it's a
lot of spending any regrets there look I
mean I've been a deficit Hawk my entire
time I just alluded to that now but I've
also been a pro-growth tax person and so
you end up in this place you know
nothing is perfect here it was about a
half a trillion dollars off on a 43
trillion dollar base something I didn't
want to see happen but at the end of the
day I'm glad I'm glad the economy is
growing I'm glad that businesses are
hiring people and wages are going up
smaller investigation where do you think
this going to end up and people say
Trump's not just tough on Russia as he
should be and I think I looked at Obama
Obama Russia rolled in
Crimea they were doing the reset that
didn't work I didn't seem like Russia
was deterred at all in the Obama
administration but you know a lot of
tried to get the lethal defensive
weapons in the Ukraine we couldn't do it
we passed a bill to make that happen and
now the the Trump administration is
sending those lethal weapon items in so
so look I I don't know anything about
what's happening with the Muller
investigation but and I heard President
Trump speak up today about the killing
of the spy in UK so I think the rhetoric
from him is getting stronger certainly
Congress on both sides of the aisle has
been pushing back and look Russia as a
problem and they're going to be a
problem likely problem China Russia size
the economy size of the military you
know Russia has got the common the size
of Italy so you know there's not much
there about they do have nuclear
armaments immediately the issue is more
it's more acute with Russia because they
try to stop all that we're doing they
try to interfere they even are
interfering with North Korea a longer
term no question China China is gonna
bypass us in all likelihood economically
and they that a foregone conclusion
China's going to bypass I'm not buying
into that I don't want them to
economically if you just look at the
numbers and you look at the the
likelihood is that that is what is going
to you know you look at us having 320
million people you look at them having
you know a billion two or three just the
economics and the numbers do you think
Trump is doing the right thing on the
tariff Sun and standing up to China
saying you're done well I wish you'd
focus more on China I'll just be honest
I mean it looks like we're trying to
punish our allies when the focus should
be multilaterally I know you don't like
that word but against China so I don't I
don't like the way we're going about it
and that looks like we're maybe trading
off NATO dues or something like that so
how do we get leverage against the EU
though when we have a hundred fifty
billion dollar trade deficit with them
we have a sixty eight billion dollar
trade deficit with Japan South Korea
trade deficit going up we now have some
leverage with them do we not that isn't
not the way to get if your focus on
trade deficit you
focus on steel with them you'd focus on
steel with China which is producing 49
percent of the world's steel so I don't
like the way that we've gone about it I
don't I've said that and I think we
should be far more focused on China as
you mentioned and in overtime they are
the entity that's stealing our
intellectual property there they've got
a program I mean we've got a now
president-for-life there work out for
freedom it's it looks oh they are going
to be the longer-term challenge for us
and one that is much bigger and as you
know being who you are history says that
when one power potentially surpasses the
other economically that creates conflict
and so it's going to be the most
difficult issue for us to manage now why
do you think the president's approval
rating is higher than Congress's today
look I don't smile so favorably on
Congress either I like the people that I
work with many of them are very very
smart most of them are very hardworking
but just the way it's always been it's
kind of like lawyers and and you have a
good relationship though outgoing with
the president I know you speak with him
regularly I mean you've had a lot of
tough words for him and he's had three
vice versa but you know he called look
were to harden those business guys and
you know he called Friday night he picks
up the phone to talk about whatever he
wants to talk about call me today and
and yeah we've got a very warm
relationship as we do throughout the
administration so it's never stopped
there might have been some public words
but we kept okay keep it in the family
it's really good to have you on thank
you so much thank you joy - thanks a lot
appreciate it